[Music]
consider the inherent paradox the
following idea
to experience something again for the
first time sounds absurd right how is it
possible that you can't experience
something again for the first time
there's only one first time there's only
one time when you can experience
something with the hardly bearable
ecstasy of direct energy exploding on
our nerve endings right it's it's it's
just not built into our Constitution or
our wiring there's something called
familiarity breeds boredom there's
something called hedonic adaptation the
point being once you've had an
experience you can't have it again for
the first time you can have it again for
the second time or the third time but
never again for the first time and yet
the goal of all contemplative practices
is a return to the deep neck a return to
the present beyond the pin there's and
seen dad's of the annulled mine that
inevitably cloud our capacity to
ostensibly have a fresh experience the
astounding frontier of the present is
constantly eluding us because we're
trapped in a monkey mind of future
anxiety and melancholy for the past and
that prevailing dread haunts the human
animal like nothing else
[Music]
I talk about this a lot because like all
of you we all secretly want to get back
to the sides of our cells that we were
tapped into his children we all want to
be more creative we'll want to be more
engaged with the people that we love you
don't want to enter with Diane Ackerman
calls states of deep play we spend money
to go to the movies to become completely
immersed in a neder world right we want
to go on the hero's journey and slay the
dragon we want our lives to be infused
with meaning we want a matter we want to
struggle we want to climb the summit of
the mountain we want to have
realizations right epiphany is that
crack has opened a little bit we want to
bring that back to the villagers we want
to share that deep truth we want a truth
bomb it so it goes bad you get in
contemplative practices all these things
they're all trying to sell us a way to
rid ourselves of our clunkiness right to
rid ourselves of our lenses of
perception to transcend to cleanse the
doors of perception Michael Pollan has a
great line he says a sense of first
sight unencumbered by knowingness it is
interesting because we love to learn we
love to grow we love to know
understanding is a kind of ecstasy said
Carl Sagan and yet even though
understanding is a kind of ecstasy
understanding for the first time is what
we really get off on and so it points
actually inherently to the importance of
forgetting as an important variable in
our happiness too we got to forget that
we learned something so that we can
learn it again right to have a sense of
first sight unencumbered by knowingness
that virginal noticing of the sense8
world requires us to somewhat forget
that we learned this before that we've
been there before right we're not just
going to new places but we're searching
for ways to seat the home world with new
eyes and they say this is enlightenment
they say this is illumination right when
the doors of perception are cleansed
everything will be revealed to man as it
is infinite
I'm exhausted both literally and
figuratively from trying to convey to
you that I to share this angst and this
hunger to enter these childlike states
of aw and referee's I think all the
Romantic poets were tortured so love
with broken psyches nonetheless longed
to see the world in a grain of sand to
see heaven in a wild flower to
hold goddamn infinity in the palm of our
hands and hold goddamn eternity
in an hour right there's a reason why we
get goose bumps and hairs in the back of
our necks to end up when we hear these
guys talk about are the only people for
me are the mad ones mad to live mad to
talk mad to be saved are we all desirous
of everything at the same time those who
never yawn or say a commonplace thing
the burn burn burn like yellow ruin
candles exploding like spiders
across the sky why do we hang these
quotes in our classroom walls why did my
mom hang those quotes in her classroom
walls and I came as a student somewhat
anxious somewhat curious somewhat hungry
for answers and better questions and I
see it written on the wall minds are
like parachutes they only function when
open the only thing standing in your way
is you
so I looked at the window of the
classroom like we all do looking out the
window of our metal coffins locker Percy
said that the search for God the truth
the search is what anyone would
undertake if they went out sunk and the
everydayness of their own lives if they
were not chained
by the everydayness of their own lives
we created these systems and we hold
these systems in place but then these
systems hold us in place
- we've entrapped ourselves and - even
become aware of the search is to be on
to something
oh the possibility of something and not
to be on to something
dicker not to be on to something
is to be in despair is to be slowly
dying is to be living a life of quiet
desperation it's the reason why I have
for these authors that wrote half of
these truth bombs end up killing
themselves in the end ready because the
alternative to this illumination to this
sense of foresight unencumbered by
knowing this to this Platonic ideal the
alternative to that his unconsciousness
in the default setting is the rat-race
is the constant gnawing soul deadening
sense of having had and lost some
infinite thing
[Music]
but we don't surrender if we will
prevail we will continue to rage against
the darkness against our darkness I went
to God just to see and I was looking at
me she wrote maybe at the end of all our
travels we'll come back into ourselves
to find what we were looking for that's
a reason to get out of bed in the
morning